Thank you.
So it's obviously been number one for how long?
It was number one on the actual charts for three weeks.
I mean, it was on radio for a while.
Are you famous now?
I don't know.
I mean, New Zealand's so small.
And I don't feel like anyone can be too famous in New Zealand...
...because it's such a small place.
I mean, we only have four million people there.
Four million?
Yeah, in the whole country.
So it's really small.
So, I mean, I don't know, I'm not sure.
I see, I wasn't quite sure about the thing written here.
Can you tell us how it got started?
I mean, these sheets thing.
The song was on the Internet first...
...and then somebody spread the word.
How about this TV2?
Yes.
Can you tell us?
Ah, yes. So I released the album online for free.
And then it was up for about three months.
And during that time, I think within the first couple of weeks, the local TV station...
...and Channel Two heard the track "Love, Love, Love" and picked it up for the TV2 thing.
So they used it for the brand commercials.
From there it went to radio and it got bigger that way.
Okay, and it also sort of really healed the people who got hurt and wounded,...
...I mean, emotionally wounded after the earthquake.
I think it came out at the right time for the New Zealand public...
...because at the time that it got big in New Zealand, this quake happened.
And it was just an uplifting song for us.
It was good for New Zealand in the end.
It's really uplifting and it's sort of forward-looking.
Yeah.
People like it, that's why.